so let me explain the backstory last
night
after my six plus hour stream
i got a message from silo simon
and it was a github github repository
which i clicked on and
shout out to this person mark dev
chest factory hall of fame who
looks like coded some script to find
leachate's games
that end with on passant checkmate
so there are 25 games on this list
people who understand code might have a
better understanding of
oh i kind of understand this so average
rating is about two thousand
um there's probably some function
that determines on passant mates
anyway we have 25 games
that i brought into the study all of
which ended on poisson nate
now i've had this twice in my life i
should probably add my games
at some point to this study
but i want to go through them and share
the variety of ways
that you can get on poisson checkmates
and for most of these we will look like
towards the very end of this game
towards the very end of the game um and
then i'll try and rank them
so like out of all the games i'll try
and find like the best ever
on poisson checkmate so hopefully this
will be really exciting we're starting
with this position
which already i see is made in two
starting with bishop c3
black has one legal move e5
now this pawn can be captured by two
different pawns
but of course we on passant discovered
is this considered discovery check or on
passant check
and mate so that's a nice one it was a
nice little uh
maiden 2 puzzle moving on i have not
seen these games
prior i just loaded them into the study
so this game oh this game it looks like
yeah black's gonna win let's see how it
happens
queen g6 some king's indian line
rock h1 ooh
bishop here coming off so the king has
no more escape squares
so white plays check
king g7 then g4 g4 would be a great move
if not for on poissant checkmate man
a g4 is probably one of the worst moves
but white's probably getting mated by
force
g4 is such a nice way to end the pain
okay that was number two let's keep
moving
uh again we'll jump to the end ooh
oh so white's up a queen here white
played this move
thinking let's make a new queen black
misses
black had bishop e5 or played rook d1
fearing that white will queen bishop e5
is already made in two which was played
the next move
gave way the chance to escape but now
sees it bishop e5
only legal move is f4
and then on poisson oh no white's king
ouch i wonder if black saw bishop e5
maybe just didn't like it anyway
okay so yet another on passant made in
two
let's keep moving thank you toxic
penguins for the sub
again we're looking for the most
beautiful on passant mate
how is this going to end so white one
oh so is this pawn gonna be moving
forward
look at this move rook g4
wait is that a good move oh it is
okay so takes takes forcing king here
i feel like the most common form of on
passant mate is when you
give a bishop check at forcing the pawn
to move two squares forward
and then you have a pawn to discover the
bishop for meat
oh that's so nice this is the top one so
far
with the rucksack let's make a note here
rook sack
of course there is king h7 but black uh
black took the bait and ran into on
poisson mate
okay we're moving on
ooh this is a quick one
white one connect four and then proceeds
to expand the pawns
this reminds me of that weird what is
that weird emoji
squiggly face emoji this emoji right
where i don't even know how you make
that face
uh anyway yeah the pawns are like
smiling but also kind of frowning
and anyway white gets the v-shape
how is this going to be oh bishop's
going to come here
wait for it wait for it check
so this is a very important moment
because it's not every day you have two
legal on passant
both moves are on poisson checkmate for
some reason i thought this isn't
checkmate
but you both moves are checkmates
so what does white choose white plays
de-6
which i think is a small inaccuracy you
should take always take towards the
center
then you have three center pawns but
this is
double this is the best one so far i
think
double on croissant mate other one was
nice but this
like you have two options wow
double assant yeah we have to make some
new french words
what does sockfish choose oh
it was indecisive for a moment there
but yeah i prefer zf6 because you
sockfish favors the center okay moving
on
zoom forward
oh queen h1 queenish one is such a sad
move
now queen c7 or queen yeah queen g6 or
c7
forcing f4 and these pieces do
nothing to defend the king from on
poisson checkmate
and this is nice because you need the
pawn to come here
or no you don't g2 is already controlled
but you control it
again for good measure
that was nice white looks so ridiculous
here
it's like um a croissant
okay moving on alekhine's cat
zooming forward so white's gonna win ooh
queens are traded
white's down two exchanges here and a
pong
but white has secret plan in mind
man it's so common like bishop check f
pawn moves and then on passant
checkmate this is this is nice
without because most of the other
positions have been without it or
have been with a queen this is without a
queen
and white was down material
so this position like before
rook here which was a natural move
black's completely winning like boxer
should just
take the pawn yeah the best way to stop
on poissant
is to remove remove all the pawns on the
fifth rank
okay again we're going to zoom forward
white's getting crushed
oh the same pattern yeah f pawn moves in
the on poisson
i feel like the most common on poisson
made is e takes f3
or e takes f6
chest factory will have to code a new
script to
give us some stats uh let's keep moving
again we check along this diagonal e
takes f3 mate
okay so we're beginning to see a pattern
uh let's jump ahead again
ef6 mate
it's crazy because when you think of on
poisson checkmate you wouldn't expect
there to be like
of a very specific on poisson
capture but i guess it's common
of course this is super rare but when it
does happen it's most common for the
f pawn to be moving and the king to be
on h7 or h2
so i'm kind of looking for more unique
situations
again he takes that three
hey f paula thanks for gifting five
appreciate that i mean i hope people are
being entertained like we can already
see that white's gonna win
with e takes f6 yeah
oh this is nice though could we white
sacked the rook black should be winning
in this
position yeah rook d8 and these squares
are defended and this is covered
okay oh
[Music]
you would not expect on passant mates
happen from this position
so it's going to be white winning
white's down two pawns and a rook bishop
and the end game
maiden two this is made in two
black was so innocent black just
innocently defended the
g-pawn because how else do you defend
the g pawn
made in two
bishop h4 you
like there's so few pieces on the board
the king's
in a close to central square you don't
expect it to get mated when white just
has
rook bishop and few pawns but g5 is
forced
and each g6 is made because the bishop
controls this diagonal um
the rook controls and defends g6 and
these pawns are clutch
wow end game
wow i mean white was basically just
losing up until
right yeah white's just just dead here
and then out of nowhere even up until
like this position
and okay there's there's a few moves
like rook c2 and these pawns are going
to run
wow king f6 this is crazy because king
f7
king f6 looks like the most natural move
too all these pawns
except this pawn but these pawns all
play a purpose
let's keep moving so we're we're more
than halfway
through the games there's 25 total we're
on game 14.
i'm making comments for all the notable
ones we have the endgame wow
the without a queen the double on
passant mate and the rucksack
uh let's keep going um
what why is a king wait what is this
game
oh it's kind of a it's a closed sicilian
oh this is cool well box king just took
a walk
white's king also may be taking a walk
what is this and how is
how is it going to end with on poisson
mate and
okay i see white wins so f4 oh the king
walks further
opposition what a position
queen f2 okay always repeat oh
so after queen g3 of course black should
run back
oh but then there's queen g6 so black
walks forward
and now here queen g7
the skewer from behind
e5 is forced completing
some sort of diamond formation and now
on passant mate from behind
that's crazy it's like the and it's a
skewer not that it matters that the
queen is on b2
but uh the what do we call this
the backwards on poisson mate backwards
on poissant because most of the examples
almost all of them have been like
you check the king a forward check
not a backward check
but when the pawn so whenever you on
poissant like this diagonal
and this diagonal opens and you you
always usually think forward but
the diagonals also open backwards
that was really nice plus a skewer
plus skewer a very nice shish kebab
okay that was nice and keep moving along
where was white's queen
boates gambit i'm already excited about
this one
so white was excited to attack the rook
lost a queen walks into a windmill
leaves the king suffering
so white's threatening um if rick p8
white has this and mate
so black plays bishop f6 we check
check another yeah this is a beautiful
windmill
white has made in one but chooses not to
made in one
because after f5
on poissonmates
that was a cool one botez gambit
or oh no my queen basically synonyms
okay that was nice and it was discovered
check mate on poisson discover checkmate
i guess most of these are discovery
checkmates okay
we're moving on
king's on the run
oh another yeah this is another classic
one
not the typical f-pawn move but uh takes
and mate
it's still beautiful but uh
not as knowable as these other ones it's
tough when you're comparing
it's like comparing fine works of art to
one another like you have to be even
more selective
okay so white's gonna win
ooh oh g5 thinking black's defending
but gets mated in one
we'll call this g5 g5 double
or quadruple quintuple question mark g5
is like the worst possible move
this is a non-discovered on poisson mate
because usually we're unleashing like a
bishop diagonal
but this time it's a you on passant with
a pawn doing the check
yeah that's probably more rare
non-discovery
okay oh this game national master the
lord of the board
i think this is the shortest game 14
move on pass on me let's see how this
happens
comes from um a dumb french
alakan it's like when you mix up the
alkyne in the french
so black just becomes passive
white gets a nice ooh like it's a greek
gift setup
ooh greek gift very typical but how does
this end in
on poisson mate
oh i see what's coming look at this
so h5 forcing the king to one of these
squares
f6 is probably better but this is more
beautiful
white's queen is attacked but white
doesn't care white takes discover
check also unleashing the queen
black has three legal moves this
this and this
all of them lose instantly so black
plays g5
this is the most beautiful way to lose
look at this move
on poisson double check
mate in 14 moves
we saw double on poisson earlier but
this is on poisson
double checkmate
double i think this is our first double
mate when two pieces are mating the king
bishop g5 is not legal whenever you're
in double check
there's no you can never create a
situation
where there's double check that can be
um responded to by blocking or capturing
whenever there's two pieces attacking
the king
you always have to move the king no
exception unless you're mated then you
you just cry in sadness
or you admire your opponent's beauty
that's nice and the knight is clutch
controlling g7
that's really nice this might this might
be the winner so far
after 14 moves to get a mate like this
and the game was actually kind of
logical
with a greek gift as well uh
let's keep moving we have six more
oh this is also 14 moves
another french type position is this
going to be the same thing
this is like almost the same thing but
slightly different
that's so funny oh
the whoever played this like the first
game should sue the other
other player for copyright trademark
infringement
uh we'll just say copyright infringement
it's the same thing oh i thought that
was so unique
it's just the same did i skip
oh i skipped game 18. wait a minute i
skipped game 18
let's look at game 18 so i skipped over
this game mistakenly because i got so
excited
about the other ones oh this is a
classic one
okay so we've seen this example
many times okay moving on so now we have
five more the final five
or zooming forward
end game oh another yeah another e takes
f3
again most common mates based on these
these games are ef3
if you're black or ef6 if you're white
maybe that's a real copyright
infringement i don't know or maybe
that's fair use
oh this is another french oh is this
going to be another
it's going to be another greek gift it's
probably going to be the same thing
h4 is nice because we we're still
threatening the stacks
it's going to be the same thing man this
whole sequence like starting with bishop
h7
knight g5 the king comes to g6
uh and then we eventually like discover
check and then mate
wow
uh more copyrights
it's crazy how this is like surprisingly
common
but also so beautiful
it's like um
like a double rainbow or triple i don't
know
[Music]
it's like one of these solar eclipses it
probably happens
every few years but every time it
happens like it's so astonishing
it's so funny these greek gift games
also i should mention i think um
because a knight is here black can just
move back and queen h5 is met with
knight f6 and black is probably just
worse
black's losing but black was willing to
be a
victim of art i have a few more another
oh this is going to be the same thing
ah it's the same thing
oh that's so funny the first example we
saw in this
i thought it was gonna be like the
standouts but this is just a recurring
thing for some reason
[Music]
and this isn't something that's easy to
find like using the opening book
because all of these games are unique
but
yeah special thanks again to chess
factory for
i guess compiling the list and we're
beginning to see some patterns
um now it's on my bucket list to get a
mate like this
have to play against the french more
often
okay two more let's see if oh 17 moves
another french-like position
oh okay this this is a more unique one
this is a nice miniature
bishop c4
on passant in the center
that's a nice one let's call this unique
miniature
because this is the shortest game that's
like a more unique idea
compared to the other ones that we saw
and then this one
okay what
i clicked word assuming like some normal
opening
[Music]
so yeah black is probably
these players are probably like secret
accounts of hikaru and magnus
and raided in the like low 2000s for
some reason it started off normal
blackmart deemer somewhat normal
and then king d7 and white wanted to
join the party
and then black regretted the decision
very quickly
i feel like black's trying to lose
this is another case with double we saw
this
one game earlier double
on poissant but this is this is
bong cloud passant or double
i don't even know what to call this let
me save the name of the players
double bong cloud passant
mate i feel like anarchy chess would
like this game
and this is another one this is unique
in sony regard because it
comes from a bond cloud type opening
it's a non-discovery like the pawn is
delivering the check
um which i think we've seen is more
unique
and white has two options
it would be i'm slightly disappointed
white
or black didn't like play one more move
just so white could win connect four
and then play e5 and then win connect
five with on poisson checkmate
this would have been most beautiful
but this is still acceptable
anyway okay there is a 25 games i'll
probably put all of that on youtube
maybe do some cutting
i hope people enjoy that this is a
celebration
of 20 years of learning how to play
chess
so it was a fun it was a fun experience
to go through these games big thanks
again to
this github developer mark dev
uh i'll leave the link in the video
description and twitch chat
along with the leachat study and
if you're watching in the future on
youtube be sure to subscribe and i'll
see you in the next video